police in Tunisia have arrested three
prominent officials of the main
opposition party hours after detaining
its leader and raiding its headquarters
police say another leader rashidranushi
was detained for questioning on the
orders of the public prosecutor granushi
is a main opponent of president
khaisayed
who has been accused of orchestrating a
power grab after he suspended parliament
in 2021
is the daughter of detained the detained
another leader she joins us now from
London good to have you with us so first
of all do you have any word on the
status of Rashid ranushi is he just
simply taken in for questioning or is he
under arrest for something
well since the coup my order has been
interrogated nine times summoned for
interrogation for which he willingly
presented himself uh nine times for
frequently politically motivated and
fabricated childish but this time the
coup authorities chose to read my
parents house at the time of breaking
the fast on the 27th night of Ramadan
a hundred to include policemen raided
the house half of whom went in and
prevented the lawyers from observing the
search and after searching the house for
two hours they took my father for
interrogation but they could have simply
summoned him but he was taken and and
lawyers were
prevented from joining him for
interrogation
has he been charged do you know if he's
actually been charged with anything this
time
uh lawyers have not been given any
information officially about the
official charge but we have heard
reports in the Trinity media and the
interior Minister yesterday stated that
my father has been arrested because of
statements he has made and just now the
public prosecution issued a statement uh
alleging that my father made a
provocative statements and that he had
said misquoting his words that he had
said that the eradication of islamist in
Tunisia would lead to Civil War whereas
the statements which were not in a
leaked with you but in a live Facebook
feed from a public meeting at the
national salvation front headquarters
where he was talking about the national
salvation front success in bringing
together political parties and
intellectual Trends in Tunisia in
opposition to the coup where he said
word for word that imagining Tunisia
without any uh would it without this or
that group without another without the
left without islamists would be laying
the ground for Civil War uh uh so this
is clear misquoting and
misrepresentation of my father and and a
new uh attempt to demonize the political
uh opposition to the coup this is part
it is in the context of The Witch Hunt
uh against not just a number but all
political parties and all Civil Society
organizations that have been standing
against the crew by Faisal and who have
been calling for a restoration
opportunity and democracy right since he
was taken there have been three other
members of anata who have been arrested
are you concerned that all of this is
simply a Prelude to perhaps shut down
tunisia's you know one of tunisia's
largest political parties
we fear that this is possible because
since the coup we have been
the rule of law without any respect of
Rights and and freedoms
and not just a number but as I have said
all critics face Heights coup and his
paragraph and his uh failure to manage
the economy to provide any solutions to
take Tunisia out of its Christ and his
insistence on taking Tunisia back to a
dictatorship anyone who criticizes this
is a target of bayside's repression
whether it is a number or anybody else
and we do fear that this is uh an
escalation of the Crackdown on the
opposition and we believe anyone who
believes in democracy and human rights
around the world should clearly and
explicitly condemn this persecution of
the opposition and this systematic
dismantling of Tunisian democracy all
right thank you so much
thank you